[Music]
like your past bosses I can't speak
right now I did you spoke perfectly I
think you did it I can't grandma right
it's the freaking mercury record retro
what I was trying to ask is have you
guys ever had bosses or CEOs and
companies that you worked in that we're
generally - like perceived to be
overweight and tall guys like big over
with fat overweight guys yeah oh what is
there like you're gonna talk about like
there's like an unhealthy boss
stereotype or something or no no no
probably that there's a correlation
between like being big and fat and like
being focused maybe you're powerful none
of my bosses are a big or fat yes I've
had a big bonded lady boss well had a
lady boss too but they're referring
mailbox had a boss with a potbelly but
he wasn't like a big did you work at a
successful business yes successful chain
oh actually Andy and the other male
bosses were also a happy yeah okay the
company I work for made three million
dollars a day whoa is that a lot I think
I don't even think that's how much damn
Iceman burn me with that [ __ ]
freezing cold dry ice it's wintertime
everybody oh no okay a recently
published research article at Cornell
University found that weights among men
is positively associated with perceived
persuasiveness what in other words is
that why they say why are you throwing
your weight around is that a thing
yeah like it's like your power your way
yeah yeah yeah going throw my weight
around yeah your influence
so they're saying that overweight men in
a workplace are thought to be more
persuasive than average-sized men you
know why cuz fat guys be like hey you
want to go lunch you're like now I'm
trying to be on a diet goes you sure
about that you want to try this and that
and you're like I'll go you with your
fat ass
he's like no he said no I'm gonna die -
we're gonna PF Changs it's like [ __ ]
candy chicken yeah so they're saying
that you know back in the day like way
way way back in the day how Batman
overweight men were seen as very wealthy
and oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
same with fat girls - right because back
then it was harder to come by
good so then if you see sometimes
overweight you're thinking oh they're
wealthy they're doing some [ __ ] right
but Franklin was fat as [ __ ] I know
everyone was starving yeah so they're
like how'd you get so much food I only
get like a bean a day like Kings yeah
for sure
you said well I was important to think
about a fat guy getting his portrait
done and he's like fattest [ __ ] and he's
got his leg up on a thing like for
whatever reason Captain Morgan so weird
yeah yeah I mean even these days like
like what let's say I start gaining
weight in a video within snow sleet it's
noticeable in a vlog like calms me out
Tim eating good money must be good Tim's
eating good oh my god Wow
that's them being fancy people just like
hey Stevie look it's fattest [ __ ] my
arm sure no one says that
what's getting better it's getting
better working on that's how I thought
about the rapper's yes like Rick Ross or
like Fat Joe like there's just a certain
presence to them they're both skinny now
just like slim job yeah slim Joe and
Rick Ross is like pretty thin what he's
thinning you know I trust fat people
more with North their food
recommendations just like they won't
[ __ ] me over what what when you talk
about the hefty bosses being more
persuasive I do kind of remember a boss
that I really liked he's a big dude and
he was just so like jolly yeah Joey is
like a man like is this chair crack when
he's talking to you mm-hmm
that's also distracting if he's like Tim
let me tell you about your future
if this chair is having a tough time
during that conversation that would I
have the stereotype of like fat guys
being very friendly and jolly and not
threatening and what about fat girls Joe
I don't have one oh I'm not allowed to
have one I'm
thanks for what's the article about it
this whole video I just want Joe to
elaborate on what he's saying anyway so
they were saying here that women the
same assumption was not made about women
annoying
yeah but how everyone's scared too
that's why no they're saying one of the
experiments showed that heavier women
tend to be expected to have a better
sense of humor so they were more damn if
you're a fat girl and you're not funny
that's rough that's true I always say
you know and I've said this before it's
like when you're somebody who didn't
grow up as like people calling you hot
all the time you develop a better sense
of humor because my personality even cuz
you kind of for them you got em yeah you
got to make up for the you got to get
attention in different ways you don't
saying that's why I always say yo short
news are where it's at you know Todd
dudes get the attention as soon as they
walk in with the exception of Steve of
course I don't get that much attention
yeah I feel like Todd dudes walk into a
room and girls like oh this [ __ ]
is tall right but like short news we
gotta bring it back down so I feel like
we're usually you know look down here
[ __ ] hit four funnier you know
better dressed smell better or meaner if
you got the little man complex yet
wholly on you were building a good case
and then TIFF came and was like [ __ ] no
get some really really bitter those are
the insecure ones yeah the short guy
they're just like don't stop get all
like that angry babe okay yeah I mean
for him I think is doing it on purpose
but they're actually real people like
that well if you make anything if you go
into an indie extreme with anything you
become very annoying well yeah if you're
extremely obsessed with how short you
are or how tall you are you're [ __ ]
weird every time you're so insecure it's
like guys who go to [ __ ] masculinity
message boards and talk about how they
want to be more masculine [ __ ] it's like
dudes you guys are getting too obsessed
with the [ __ ] like it's it's annoying
any type of obsession mm-hmm yeah so for
this one that we're saying that bigger
dudes it gets more positive know that
they tend to be viewed as more
persuasive and they get all the sales on
the pants at the department stores cuz
they always have run out let me up
no Big Boi sales in a work environment
they're seen as someone that you can
trust more because it because of like
what's ingrained in us from so like
they're saying like before the
Industrial Revolution made food cheaply
available for everyone
that's when larger men were viewed as
like oh you're doing some [ __ ] right I
gotta follow what you're doing so they'd
be more they're like the rich guys back
then cuz it before money it was like
where'd you get that food how'd you get
that cuz now it's like you kind of think
of that about guys are super rich like
how'd you get that money can you teach
me and if someone's fat back in a day if
you're like man I'm skinny as [ __ ] I
only eat like one fish a week how you
eat fish every day right I mean dude
here we have fat homeless people that's
true it's pretty crazy
buff ones too buff once I've seen some
rip ones really yeah they're jacked but
if you go to most other countries like
their portions are smaller their foods
cleaner like more organic and all that
[ __ ] right and then most people are just
smaller in frame yeah even as even when
you just cross over to like Canada like
when she had first art coming over here
she was shocked at how different the
portions are between like let's say
McDonald's out here and McDonald's in
Canada really yeah she'd be like she's
like what the [ __ ] is where she would go
grocery shopping she was like yo this is
crazy
these portions where she would like to
show me what a small coffee wasn't
Canada it's looks like it's like this
big babies coffee yeah yeah so even just
right up there are neighbors up north
you know NAB different portions the
weird ones I went to Denmark and got
McDonald's and I thought I was getting
ripped off because it was so small that
was [ __ ] small it's small and
expensive yeah I don't even know why
yeah it's communist that's why mhm
everything communism nice everything's
coming up yeah I'm just kidding it's not
a communist country no just say it's how
many there's no that's fun I'm an
American so everything else is comedy
that's what I did
yeah yeah but I think that there is
something wired in our brains about like
fat people on if it's cultural or
biologic just like tall and bigger
because they're saying okay your
presence yogurt yeah there's a bigger
presence so then you end up looking
towards these men for leadership there's
also more gravity and things have more
mass right so they suck you in that's
true I mean when I think about my
favorite sitcom dad's to
think of like Carl Winslow he's fat and
Uncle Phil rest in peace yeah yeah yeah
I mean they do pull me closer to the
screen with the gravity - that's true
when you think of like fat older guys
you think like comfortable and like Joey
yeah jolly and yeah like I mean if you
see a skinny older guy you feel sorry
for them cause this guy have a disease
yeah I didn't get that but mr. burns
yeah mr. Berge he looks like oh the
Grinch
yeah oh right right compared to like the
mythical creation so true very good
example no I'll go felt like you could
see him and he was actually big making
your life yeah who's a skinny sitcom dad
they don't make them to look at dude huh
Danny Turner tanner Oh Bob Saget yeah I
guess I didn't trust him no because he
was skinny right damn that makes sense
but he doesn't seem like a leader though
no he seems like a pushover yeah he was
like trying to figure out how to raise
all these kids on his own that's what he
had his brothers help them yeah have you
met anyone who actually watches fuller
house no I haven't either I tried was it
good I think there's a [ __ ] full
blown conspiracy on this yeah who's
actually watching the show well I have a
confession is that I never watched full
house when you're a kid I just I didn't
think it was funny as I knew his family
matters oh you never watched family
matters why would I watch both of those
step-by-step was my [ __ ] but family
matters was my [ __ ]
it's like the modern-day Brady was like
I can't remember a [ __ ] episode of
that show but I watched it every week I
remember [ __ ] Cody like yeah yeah I
remember him what step-by-step so it's
modern day Brady Bunch so is this guy
that had kids but they weren't all one
gender so he had kids from a previous
marriage and then the mom from another
marriage and then they got together I
just know that ever heard of that roller
coaster show cuz okay the roller coaster
and I always thought oh man they're at
the Six Flags I go to I would see the
same ride but then I would see the waves
and the beach and I what is it yeah cuz
that's a little kid I couldn't
understand that there was multiple six
wagons how do you say multiple six five
six five six wise yeah I was tripping
out when I found out it was a six flag
in North Cal right and I was like wait
you have a Magic Mountain do they know
it's called Six Flags we had a place
called Kings Dominion that was my Six
Flags Virginia scary on the right is
this roller coaster called the grizzly
with my dad my little brother and it was
[ __ ] like so Rikki Rockett II my dad
had to hold my little bow in the ride to
Cuba from fly it out pretty janky that's
what it sounds like Kings Dominion that
place sounds I got sticky floors oh yeah
no it sounds like ass [ __ ] dirt
floors
sounds like somewhere a Harry Potter fan
would go before they had into Hogwarts
man I just want to ride the rickety
rackety giddy hearty I want to feel like
I'm about to die on a roller coaster
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you